[Music]
the basic rule here is uh he's enclosed
bar don't stay down
here get Get Up Stand Up okay most of
his attacks are down here uh the knee
pulls down here then all his attacks his
counters and those are much more ly then
if I stand up and he makes me go uh
sweeps me going rearward
okay uh cost and benefits is in favor
standing up okay so you have a couple
options a lot of it has to do with what
he's doing in your own physical
conditioning so just looking at your
legs you can post up on one you kind of
bring your leg out on this side and then
you can kind of just turn your knee
okay but understand like from our guard
control techniques is you do one leg at
a time you're very vulnerable to the
knee pool on the second one so you
should try to get up at the same time
and then towards that end you just have
to play The Leverage game okay so we'll
do the first one from the bicep
ties you're here bring your face over
his face and your legs come up
so bicep
tie face over his face legs come up and
then seek
height seek height
okay all right track next
way other than the bicep ties you'll
come up into this the armpit area okay
so I'm like this armpit everything's the
same though my head goes towards his
face my legs come up and I see
K again
hook move towards his head up you come
SE P okay we'll try that so whichever
one you use uh once you come up as you
guys saw like a lot of times you just
the guy lets go okay
but he might
not so when you come up you can just
push on both or push on one then you
you'll break the
door be mindful that depending on how
wide you came up because your
physicality your leg is what's keeping
them up so you can push after you move
that leg in okay all right we'll try
that all right so you came up up you
push and you're going to come out this
way and you come out
forward you have your for
op
out for options okay so wherever you are
let's say uh he's got uh some hook on my
arm Okay so same thing you're just going
to do the same thing so my hands are
here his hands are occupied so I don't
have to do bicep ties I just come up
shift your weight you're up slip out
boom same
thing one more time so got that shoulder
lock but your hand is there bring your
weight forward your head towards his
head up you go palmel out push come out
forward okay try all right so this time
he has the overhook on the arm make sure
you have the same thing okay hands on
the mat head over him sit up P out break
off
again over top there you arm Bo P out
boom out okay this one guys like double
under hooks you're here okay same exact
thing Boom come here this way keep
it it was too heavy because his hands
are occupied you can just come here on
his face then you're in the same
boat you always have the option again
especially now cuz he's already got you
tight like that right you can do this
one at a time if you need that strength
and then you just p push in boom you're
up boom out okay but the IDE all the
principles remain the same okay
try all so for whatever reason he got a
hold of my ankles but as I was saying
this is what your holes are doing is
making it difficult for him uh to grab
my ankles for a sweep okay also if you
pay attention like let's say I'm here
and he go he goes to grab my legs are
really far apart right and you can just
Smash It Again forward but let's say it
happens okay you get sweet just push
right here look at his
base so right behind and there's nothing
there so you can post push and now I
sweep if I need more room I'll do
another one and then the Technic will
get up
so for what whatever reason he got the
ankle you're looking for that post out
out technical get up Force
option so if if he's a little faster and
he starts trying to angle on me you see
like
[Music]
for different types of guards or even
the arm bar what you'll do is you're
going to bring your your legs your
elbows back towards his hips
okay so you're here and I'm here like
that okay and you hold it and then if he
did what he did so he opened his guard
you would feel that you don't need to
take this time you're already
out okay
so uh let's say I'm here I I'm you're
out it's done it's a done deal okay so
always be Convent when those legs open
up but if he has it go slow keep it
guard he has it and he's trying to keep
the guard and turn that's where I
control by bringing my elbows back here
okay all right let's try